in in the late eighties you develop the
Gonzo's you became yeah identified with
and this is you know a big I mean it's
really kind of the dominant mode of
expression in poor neck and you talked a
little bit about what gonzo is and how
you came up with well in the eighties
everybody was for two reasons just
imitating Hollywood movies they would
you know you would that's all we knew
how to do and you would make a movie
with bad actors and actresses that were
hired just for their sex and we'd shoot
it on video and it wouldn't look that
great and uh but you would intend that
it was you know it's like Star Wars with
actual sexy yeah but we usually didn't
have the money to make it look like Star
Wars maybe we make it look like a soap
opera or something like that you know
days of our lives or something with
people having sex at the end but and
then maybe some of that had to do with
the fact that people were worried that
they had to make a feature because a
feature was more easily defendable it
has a clear artistic shape or yeah kind
of understand so in fact the the first
button I created this character called
but man it was a Saint the summer that
that Batman came out and the first
couple of Batman movies were features
they were but they had two interesting
different things about them the first
one was the idea was that they had a lot
of us and if that was a probably the
most interesting thing but but the more
significant thing was the fact that the
concept was that you now what I wanted
to do this thing that somebody had
suggested for an amateur movie where the
the the camera like starts on its side
it gets turned on you see the picture
outside it's turned up set on a tripod
and these two couples come around on the
side and say we're the Smiths and these
are the Joneses and we're gonna make a
porno movie
but the significant thing is they're
looking right into the camera there's a
recognition that there's a camera there
and that guy didn't understand what he
was saying to me because I took it on
and let me combine it with my butt
fetish and I'd done these hard features
for my company evil angel which I just
started an 89 as a manufacturer so I
owned my movies now and and I and I said
well girls can look right in
the camera and be sexy that's what
you're used to seeing some still
pictures from porn so I just I did that
I had girls look right into the camera
and be sexy and that just that change of
angle looking at somebody else another
looking into the camera was so much more
impact and and plus I had made 40 or 50
movies before that so I knew how to work
with the camera and it's like you know
zoom and quick and focus and whatever
I'm like talking with the camera I'm
looking at the girls and and I was good
at it camera work at that point in my
career and yeah and that really was
significant and that it became intimate
porn became intimate and and and and and
I and and as I did the first couple of
Batman movies I realized that okay I
just threw a couple of scenes in that
like kind of related to the story but
then they kind of didn't because you've
got a girl who has certain talents and
then you've got guys that can do it and
rather than then then do like a regular
porn movie where you're trying to shoot
the whole thing in two days or even one
day which people were doing like let me
just cuz I got my camera and I got a
small crew I could shoot one scene in
one day let me shoot the best scene I
can with that girl let me do a little
story in itself in one scene in the
movie and then it's got like five scenes
that's five little stories but they're
like girls are looking right into the
camera being sexy and I did these little
crazy T stories where I get in trouble
for peeking over somebody's fence or
doing something or whatever and I had
ongoing characters and stuff in the
first but man movies but the whole the
unifying thing was my character relating
to the girls in different ways and that
was imitated like crazy because it just
worked and it was a great way to shoot
porno because you're directing while
you're talking from behind the camera
and I did it I think better than some
people because I had the skills the
technical skills of working with a
camera at the time you are HIV positive
how did you my scribe that and how is
that intersect
how did that in how is that intersected
with your professional career or any of
your motivations and in fighting this
case well I had a thing as most
middle-aged men do where I wanted to
experiment with transsexuals not most I
don't know some middle-aged men too and
I was a little bit careless and I got
HIV and the interesting thing was it put
me in a situation where now I'm more
like a normal consumer where now I'm not
getting laid by porn girls at all now my
life becomes I'm like this nerdy guy who
doesn't get laid at all and I got a look
at porno to get off so I was looking at
porno to get off and my tastes expanded
and I realized though there's all sorts
of stuff that's really interesting out
there that I didn't even know existed
because I'm just worried about you know
having sex with a girl now sex became
more artistic to me it became more
interesting to me as a as a medium for
expanding our horizons as human beings
and that was significant and and my life
has turned out ten times better I think
and if I hadn't gotten HIV and you're a
family man yourself yes you're married
and you're a father have a daughter are
taking care of your daughter yes so
intellectually you are a libertarian and
how did you how did you come to
libertarian ideas oh god I was just
reading in high school and was very much
impressed by Ayn Rand and she had
arguments and ideas that were different
from the socialism that I was exposed to
in the late 60s in high school and it
just made more sense to me and I just
started thinking about stuff in my
liberal leanings from high school
changed what you know what what do you
think I'm Rand would say to you at your
situation right now
she might condemn porn oh I don't know
she's some weird ideas toward the end
although she might like let's say rocco
siffredi now he takes real strong and
she really respects that he's like Hank
Rearden and Dominique and that scene
there and he really knew how to do that
idea and in a way you know she was very
much in the fence
you do you feel like you're are you
turning into a modern day or a real-life
Howard Roark are you gonna make a
fortunately my lawyers don't think I
should talk directly to the jury however
I've been very much motivated to tell
them you know I think I should be
opening and closing also because I can
say these ideas better than they can
and the only they tend to disagree with
me you were facing how many years of
jealousy everything oh geez I don't know
it's like no no no it's like six counts
of five and and well maybe thirty seven
years or some there's no the trailer
thing is only like a two-year thing so
those are maximum sentences by the way
but I mean consistently if everything
goes against you you could spend the
rest of your life in jail
yes and so given that I mean what what
is your what's your quick summation to
the jury what's your what's your
argument that why you should not be
prosecuted why what you're doing is not
obscene why what you're doing should be
you know if not celebrated tolerant in a
free society because I didn't know I was
breaking the law you know the first
thing is you know we're a government of
laws and not men if you don't if you
don't have a law that's written that
says that okay if you do this you will
go to jail then then that's a good law
if you have a law that says well you
know we might say that this is obscene
or we might say that's obscene but we
don't really know in advance we're just
gonna maybe decide to prosecute you
that's the first number one bad thing
about this situation is that I didn't
know I was breaking the law what law did
somebody's gonna interpret that I was
breaking the law that's just really bad
that's the first number one thing the
second thing is remember when we were
young and people used to say every once
in a while that you know it's a free
country isn't it when was the last time
you heard that you know do you want to
live in the kind of country where people
can where the government can just say I
don't like you I don't like your ideas
and what you're doing and let's just put
you in jail and this is based on I mean
you
you're the head of a multi-million
dollar corporation that is selling a
product that people clearly want yes
nobody is coerced into producing it
we're consuming yes that's true
that's correct do you think you would
mention that in terms of sexuality that
people this society seems to be getting
better and improving how do you feel
about the prospects for freedom overall
I mean here you are in the dock I mean
conceivably facing effectively a life
sentence do you feel like America the
United States is becoming more of a free
of more free or less free or what's
going well I'm not sure that I'm an
expert that can answer that question I
think that with the internet and with it
certainly is the case that there are
more people that are comfortable with
pornography than ever before each new
generation the people that come along
the kids that are competing the hell out
of me and driving me out of business
because they're new and they're young
and Eric got a lot of energy and they're
better with computers than I am and they
have no moral qualms about porno you
know and it used to be it was rare that
somebody like me would come along and be
fairly intelligent and wanted to do
porno movies and was pretty good at it
and was willing to buck the the system
and say I'm gonna do it anyway now you
don't have to quite say I'm going to do
it anyway because there's so many other
people doing it and they're smarter and
they're better than me and they're all
over the place and and that tells me
that that people are much more
comfortable with it and so many more
people and with the internet you have
communication of in justices and things
like that so people can talk about these
ideas of an exchange you know well this
is a better society than that one and
that works better than that so I believe
that because of the the so much greater
communication of ideas that the world is
becoming a for your place that place in
a lot of different ways I want to thank
you John for stopping by reason TV and
talking to us today